What's going on?
everybody welcome to part 24 of the intermediate python series in this tutorial what we're going to be talking about are the
string and wrapper methods or the Dunder string Dunder wrapper methods
So these two methods are very similar and a lot of times people ask like what's the main difference in?
Reality you really can get by just with a wrapper method
But in general the Dunder string method is meant to be like a human readable
Description of your object and then the wrapper method is really it's still human
Readable ish as long as someone's usually familiar at least slightly with your object?
but also the wrapper methods more meant for just kind of
Debugging purposes not really to be something that you would actually show somebody in production or something like that
But they are interchangeable to a degree in a lot. I've seen people that just simply have a reprimanded
They don't even bother with a string method
so what exactly do they do well first of all we can show a quick example with a
Module that exists and everybody has it and we're gonna do the date/time
Module so you can either
Follow along or
Just you follow along the code or just kind of watch this part won't really be necessary that you code with me
So I'm just gonna run this real quick just so we can get into a shell
I'm gonna Import date/time, and then if I do something like this date
time dot
date/time dot now
And I'm gonna go ahead and copy this so I'm gonna keep writing that a thousand times
If I just hit enter here what we get is the wrapper method
Because we're just referencing the object we haven't asked this object to say be printed which would give us the string representation
So just printing it or just just stating the object in the shell like this returns the repre method as opposed to just
Printing it will by default give us the string method
If there is no string method it will give us the wrapper method
So if there is if there was no string method we would actually just see this
But the other way you can you can be certain of this as you could just do wrapper quite literally paste
And there you have that and also you can do string
And there you have that now. What about with our our blob Jets, right?
What and I guess also like why would you want to have string and repre methods like what's the whole point?
Well at least by default the string of reprimanded or at least what you'll have right now. Which is repper is
Worthless, so what I'm gonna go ahead and do is copy these lines and now you do want to be following along if you don't
Have this code like if you're just hopping into this tutorial
Go to Python Programming at net go to the python fundamentals part 24 and copy and paste the code
It'll be a kind of near the top of the script
so
Now what we're gonna do is
Since we got the code here. Let's go ahead and run this
Pretty sure I hit and-run there. We go. We're just hanging for a second
And now let's print
blue
Blobs and we'll just reference the Zeroeth blue blob
What we get is is absolutely
Useless all right and again, which is this is clearly a reprimand but your chances
Are you might not be alive anyway? We'll just do it again just to see okay, so yeah, we're definitely dealing with
just a wrapper and as you can see this this default repre method is useless, so
What we might want to do is actually make our own
And we saw at least one example of why you would want to do this in the previous tutorial like when we were logging
for debugging purposes
It can be really useful if your methods actually are if your objects actually have string and wrapper methods
We didn't at the time
but now we're going to add some so
Let's close this and now what I'm going to go ahead and do is head on over to
the actual blob hi, so this is the
That what we're actually importing. This is our blob class the base class anyways, they're the parent class
We are modifying that up here with the blue blobs and the red blobs and the green blobs
But we don't have to give each of these their own reprimanded
We actually just need we could just do it in this parent class here. So what I'll do is. Just come down here and
Now I'm going to go ahead and do a dunder
Repper and we just need to pass self. We do need the other donors though, and
Now we're gonna. Do is just obviously it just returns a string right and like we were saying
The reprimands really more kind of for debugging purposes. It should be as condensed as possible
We're not really. It's not really meant to be output to a console in production use it's just really for debugging
so what we're going to do is we're gonna return and
will return
the Lob and
Then the information, we're going to give on this blob basically it's going to be
size
Color and then we'll do x and y
Okay, so then we're gonna do dot format and then self dot it in fact actually we'll do color first because the color
is more important so we'll do self dot color and
Then self dot size self dot x and self dot y
So now we have reprimanded. Let's save that let's pop on over to blob world
looks good, and
Now let's print
blue Blobs
Zero and now at least we have something a little more useful we've got the color again
This is an RGB the size and then the xy coordinates location, so someone who's actually familiar
With these blob objects should be able to when they see this in any sort of debugging
Immediately no, okay. This has to be the color. I'm not certain. What six is but since we know these blob objects have
color a size and a location I can just deduce that size and then
From here these two things in parentheses
It's not totally clear what they are but it's probably xy right and we could also go to the actual
Reprimanded just to see what it actually is printing out
but that's you want to keep it as just simple as as that and just basically it's just for debugging purposes and
As you can see because we did print
that should have been a string method but
Since we don't have one it's just going to fall back to the method
But if we said if we just now reference the object we're not trying to reference the string method
It's still obviously the repre method
Now let's go ahead and add a string method. So they pulled it back up
Whoops there we go
I'm just gonna copy this cuz it's gonna be very very similar just gonna have slightly more information and just be easier to read so
Change it to string now blob
you might say
you you could either have like blob and print the seas or you might get rid of even the parentheses here and
You could say like
blob of
Color something like that
and then comma size
and
then
location
And we'll tab these over just to be as close. It's probably not Gonna be perfect. Oh
My goodness it worked it's oh that feels really good when that stuff happens, all right
It's gonna be a good day. So now let's save and run that mmm. I hope I saved it
I think I did let me check before I waste time
Yep, okay, so print now blue blobs zero and again this should be great
Yes, so we got the string version and again now if we do blue blobs
0 we get the rep reversion as opposed to obviously print gives us the string version
So it just has a little bit more information a little easier to read, but yeah, it's almost like twice as long
But now what we could do is
We close this like when we go to
Our actual blob world pie, and we do things like logging let me find the first log. Let's see tried
Raised that exception logging in so like here blob add operation
And then we were doing the like string formatting and we were just doing self dot color well instead what we could say now is
The string version of self and the string version of other blob
Right we didn't we don't have to reference any of the attributes because now we actually have something that
We could also
We could say repper rather than scream just to make our logging file even smaller, but I'll leave it there
And then again here checking if two blobs are touching this was that debugging
It's like you could change that now because again
We were just using the color
But instead we could just do the actual blobs and then I think we had another one down here, but yeah
I guess we're not doing it so we could clear this that we can save this and
Let's see what was our logging
We're on info right now and let me do an info just to
So when to add operations happen. We should see a new form of adding. I haven't seen any happen just yet
We will see one here yep
Okay, so hopefully we've got a new
Log there
let's open the log file and
Go down at the very very very bottom and sure enough. We have slightly better information here now
On our actual blobs all of us obviously have a little bit more information
We might actually want to log the repper rather than the string version of the objects
But yeah, anyway, just supposed to be an example of string and remember. I think I'll change these
and I
Must be zooming by it. Oh here. We go
Wrapper and then this repartee R. Okay all is well in the world
Let's run that one just to see
Somebody's touch these blues are touching I'm pretty sure that'll still throw a log
Even though that doesn't matter if they touch each other that blues blue blobs at the moment
But I'm waiting for these to touch each other so one of these guys got it there we go
Whoo that's a big blue blob. He's gonna be taken over soon
Okay, now check the log file again
Scroll on down to the very very bottom it's a little more concise now whoops
There we go. Oh my goodness there. We go. Yeah cool. So anyway. That's the string and repair method. It's just a couple more
Special methods that I are really useful actually to know about especially if you're writing your own
your own classes and all that so if you have any questions comments concerns
Something else you want to bring up let us know below otherwise. I will see you in another tutorial